Life begins with one cell, the
fertilized egg, that grows to a human
being with over 30 trillion cells. What
are the instructions that allow you to
become you? Let's zoom in to one cell
of your body. Cells have a long
molecule called DNA, which is the
genetic material that's passed along
from parents to offspring. If you
stretched out the DNA from just one
cell of your body, it would be two
meters in length, about as tall as you
are. Along this long strand of DNA are
specific segments that hold
instructions that tell your cells what
they're supposed to do. These segments
are called genes.
Now let's zoom in and see what a gene
is made of. The gene is a sequence of
four chemicals called nucleotide bases,
abbreviated as A, T, G and C. The
sequence of chemicals contains
information to make a functional
product, usually a protein or sometimes
a functional RNA molecule. Some of
these products are like tools or
building blocks that help to build
structures of the cells. Others carry
out chemical reactions like an
industrial factory.
A human cell has a lot of genes, about
20,000, each producing a unique product.
Some are used in all cells of your body.
However, some genes are turned on only
in certain cells, such as just your
muscle cells or just your brain cells,
and turned off in others. And some are
only used in certain times, for example,
just when you're an embryo. Thus, genes
not only contain information on what
kind of product to make, but also
instruct when and where to make it.
When a gene is turned on, it can also
regulate how much of the product should
be produced, like a dimmer switch. The
amazing thing about genes is that they
are incredibly adaptable. They are not
rigid instruction manuals, but can turn
on or off depending on what you're
doing. For example, when you exercise,
different genes turn on or off,
allowing you to build more muscle. How
do 20,000 genes turning on and off and
making different products give rise to
a living, thinking, breathing being as
interesting as you? That is a mystery
that scientists are still trying to
understand.